[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
halallweg guten Abend und willkommen
Norbert Lehmann ist auch wieder dabei
für den Sport F viel Fußball schönen
guten Abend auch von mir und das sind
die Nachrichtenthemen von
heute Gewissheit nach DNA Abgleich die
von der Hamas entführte deutsche Geisel
shaniny Luke ist
tot judenfeindliche Krawalle in der
russischen Teilrepublik Dagestan stürmt
ein antisemitischer Mob den
Flughafen und Festnahme statt
Landtagssitzung gegen den bayerischen
afdptiker Daniel hember wird ermittelt
unter anderem wegen
Volksverhetzung immer mehr Opfer im
Gazastreifen nach Angaben der Hamas sind
es mittlerweile 8300 tote von der
israelischen Armee kam eine Meldung die
aufhorchen lässt Bodentruppen hätten
eine der Geiseln im Gazastreifen befreit
eine junge
Soldatin keine Hoffnung mehr gibt es für
die Angehörigen einer 22-jährigen
deutsch-israelin ihr Tod zeige die ganze
Barbarei die hinter der Hamas steckt
sagt Bundeskanzler Scholz aus Tel Aviv
Tim
Kröger die Familie und auch die deutsche
Botschaft in Israel bestätigen dass die
israelen Shani Luk die auch die deutsche
Staatsangehörigkeit besaß im hang mit
dem brutalen Angriff der Hamas am 7
Oktober ums Leben
kam ich empfinde auf der einen Seite
Traurigkeit weil es keine Chance gibt
dass sie zurückkommen auf der anderen
Seite gibt es Gewissheit was mit ihr
passiert ist sie hat wahrscheinlich
nicht gelitten und ist ziemlich am
Anfang
gestorben rund 1400 Menschen sind
während des Massakers ums Leben gekommen
noch immer sollen sich 239 Geiseln in
der Hand der Hamas en heute Nachmittag
dann eine positive Nachricht die
Soldatin megidis wurde laut
Militärangaben während der
bodenoperation befreit und hat bereits
ihre Familie getroffen die Hamas
veröffentlichte heute Aufnahmen die drei
weibliche Geiseln zeigt von denen eine
schwere Vorwürfe gegen den israelischen
Ministerpräsidenten netanah erhebt er
habe sie nicht ausreichend beschützt für
Angehörige anderer Geiseln ein
Hoffnungsschimmer es macht uns sehr viel
Hoffnung zu sehen dass sie leben haben
sie nicht aufgegeben wir wissen dass sie
leben und werden alles tun damit Sie
nach Hause
kommen die israelische Armee dringt
unterdessen mit Bodentruppen offenbar
immer weiter in den Gazastreifen vor man
habe dutzende hamaskämpfer getötet die
massiven Zerstörungen der Kämpfe sind
deutlich sichtbar die humanitäre
Situation verschlimmert sich obwohl
gestern laut UN ein größerer konvou
hilfslastwagen die Grenze nach Gaza
überquert hat
all diese Kinder hier haben Hunger es
ist unerträglich für sie die Menschen
haben gestern die Lager gestürmt weil
sie so sehr unter Druck
standen in Jerusalem und anderen Teilen
Israels gab es heute Luftalarm in der
Stadt Netivot im Süden Israels schlug
eine Rakete aus Gaza
ein Michael bewerunge in Tel Aviv eine
Geisel ist befreit eine andere
beschimpft per Video wütend den
Ministerpräsidenten wie reagiert
Netanyahu ich hatte vor wenigen Minuten
selbst die Gelegenheit auf einer
Pressekonferenz netano persönlich die
Frage zu stellen ob denn diese
Festlegung auf militärische
Befreiungsaktionen auf militärischen
Druck der einzige richtige Weg sei die
Geiseln freiubkommen und er hat das
bestätigt er hat gesagt die Angehörigen
der Geiseln hätten alle sein
uneingeschränktes Mitgefühl aber die
Hamas würde nur ausschließlich auf
militärischen Druck reagieren und es
gebe keine Gewissheit aber wenn dann sei
das die einzige Möglichkeit die Geisen
zu befreien oder mit militärischem Druck
die Hamas zu Verhandlungen zu zwingen
und er zog natürlich auch das Beispiel
dazu dass eine soldattin tatsächlich mit
einer militärischen Befreiungsaktion
gerettet werden konnte mit großer
Abscheu ist hier in Israel und Empörung
dieses Video der drei Geiseln aus Gaza
aufgenommen worden was ja natürlich ein
Propaganda wie Video ist der Hamas und
zeigt dass die Geiseln vor allem dazu
benutzt werden einen Psychokrieg gegen
Israel zu führen danke für diese
Einschätzung live aus Tel Aviv danke
schön Michael
beberunger der Kampf gegen die Hamas ist
militärisch auch deshalb so schwer weil
die Terrorgruppe im Gazastreifen ein
weit verzweigtes Tunnelsystem
kontrolliert eine Art untergrundstaat in
dem auch Geiseln versteckt werden
Christian Semm hat
Details im gaserstreifen gibt es zwei
Welten die die man sieht und eine
unsichtbare Unterwelt ein weit
verzweigtes Tunnelsystem als Rückzugsort
für die Hamas oder Waffenlager Gänge bis
zu 40 m tief unter der Erde mit einer
Gesamtlänge von bis zu 500 km hat die
Hamas gebaut sie wird Tunnelsysteme
sowohl für Defensive als auch für
offensive Aktivitäten nutzen sie wird
Hinterhalte vorbereitet haben sie wird
Sprengfallen vorbereitet haben hinzuk
kommt es gibt unzählige Eingänge auf
freiem Feld in Häusern unter Schulen
viele Tunnel sind sehr gut ausgebaut und
mit Beton ausgekleidet teilweise so groß
dass man mit dem Motorrad durchfahren
kann irgendwo in diesem Gewirr aus
Gängen Räumen ein und Ausgängen werden
offenbar auch viele Geiseln versteckt
die aus Israel verschleppt wurden die
85-Jährige jochevet lifchitz war zwei
Wochen lang im Tunnelsystem der Hamas
gefangen das sind riesige tunnelnetze es
sieht aus wie ein Spinnennetz wir sind
durch Feuchte Tunnel gelaufen und kamen
irgendwo war in einem Raum an dort waren
vielleicht 25
Personen ein weiteres großes Problem für
das israelische Militär in den Tunneln
gibt es keinen Satellitenempfang und
kein GPS die Kommunikation funktioniert
also nur bedingt während die Hamas Kabel
verlegt hat um zu
kommunizieren die aktuelle Lage der
Zivilbevölkerung im Gazastreifen schürt
unter Muslimen in vielen Ländern Wut und
Hass wie weit geht zeigt sich gestern
Abend im Südwesten Russlands genauer in
machatkala der Hauptstadt der
Teilrepublik Dagestan wo sich viele
Menschen zum Islam bekennen eine
aufgebrachte Menschenmenge stürmte den
Flughafen nur weil dort ein Flugzeug aus
telaviv landete vor allem junge Männer
machten Jagd auf Juden Nina
Niebergall so sieht es aus wenn sich
aufgestauter Hass gewaltsam entläht Hass
auf Juden seit Wochen geschürt durch
antisemitische Hetze in sozialen
Netzwerken die im armen mehrheitlich
muslimischen Dagestan offenbar auf
besonders fruchtbaren Boden fät mehr als
1us junge Männer folgen einem Aufruf auf
telegram ihr Ziel ein Flugzeug aus Tel
Aviv in dem sie Flüchtlinge aus Israel
vermuten ein Passagier verteidigt sich
ich bin Usbeke ich spreche nur kein
Usbekisch weil ich in Russland
aufgewachsen bin willst du uns
verarschen brüllt einer der Angreifer
sie nehmen ihm den Pass Weg er war
vermutlich zufällig in den wütenden Mob
geraten das Flugzeug aus Tel Aviv wurde
rechtzeitig verbarrikadiert schlimmeres
konnte so verhindert
werden als die Polizei zum Flughafen
kommt eskaliert die Gewalt
Sicherheitskräfte prügeln auf die
Eindringlinge ein aus dem Kremmel kein
Wort darüber dass Juden geschützt werden
müssen die Position eher auf Seiten der
Palästinenser sogar Hamas waren zuletzt
in Russland stattdessen ein Bekannter
Reflex schulzer der
Westen es ist bekannt und offensichtlich
dass die Ereignisse gestern rund um den
Flughafen machatkala größtenteils das
Ergebnis äußerer Einmischung
waren fakt ist antisemitische porome gab
es in Russland lange nicht wo
Stimmungsmache gegen Juden jetzt auf
eine aufgepeitschte Bevölkerung
trifft die Eskalation in Ost ist auch
Thema eines ZDF Spezials um 19:20 Uhr
direkt nach uns jetzt zur afrikaareise
von Bundeskanzler Scholz in Nigeria
wirbt er um Zusammenarbeit in der
Energiepolitik es geht aber auch um die
illegale
Migration warum das westafrikanische
Land so wichtig ist zeigen diese Zahlen
nigeria hat mehr als 200 Millionen
Einwohner und ist die größte
Volkswirtschaft Afrikas basis dafür ist
der Export von Öl und und Rohstoffen
Stichwort Migration 14 000 Nigerianer in
Deutschland sind ausreisepflichtig wegen
fehlender Papiere konnten bisher aber
nur wenige abgeschoben werden Andreas
künas
berichtet es gibt einen Ort in Lagos
diesem 20 Millionen Menschen molloch
einen Ort für die glücklosen die es nach
Europa geschafft hatten und zurück
mussten an diesem Mittag sitzt der
deutsche Kanzler an diesem Ort den
Deutschland initiiert und finanziert wer
zu rückgekehrt ist nach Nigeria bekommt
hier Beratung Ausbildung Aufmunterung
kein großes aber vielleicht ein kleines
Glück es ist gut wenn diese Rückkehrer
eine Zukunft haben ein Einkommen einen
Job oder die Chance ein kleines Geschäft
zu
gründen bis 2050 soll die Bevölkerung
Nigerias auf eine halbe Milliarde
wachsen das Land wird dann größer sein
als die EU und viel jünger Präsident ub
hat nicht zum ersten Mal Bereitschaft
erklärt seine in Deutschland
ausreisepflichtigen Staatsbürger
zurückzunehmen passiert ist vorsichtig
gesagt
nichts ich stelle keine Bedingungen wenn
es Nigerianer sind dann sind es
Nigerianer und sie sind wieder zu Hause
willkommen wie schnell dieses Zuhause
wie schnell Lagos wächst wird den
deutschen von der Wasserseite gezeigt
eine Autofahrt wäre nicht praktikabel
die Bundes Regung biet nigerianischen
Fachkräften Handwerkern Talenten so
viele legale Wege in Deutschland zu
arbeiten wie noch nie und hofft dass
dafür die nigianische Regierung die
illegalen Wege schließt am Abend weiter
Reise nach Ghana ein sogenanntes
sicheres Herkunftsland mit relativ
wenigen
migrationsproblemen Bundesinnenminister
Feser ist ebenfalls in Afrika in Marokko
auch dort geht es um Abschiebungen und
zugleich um das Anwerben von Fachkräften
bislang hatte Marokko wenig Interesse an
der Rückführung seiner Staatsbürger das
soll sich nun ändern Deutschland will
mehr Anreize bieten etwa eine verstärkte
Zusammenarbeit beim Grenzschutz und bei
der Terrorbekämpfung laut
Bundesinnenministerium Leben in
Deutschland
3660 ausreisepflichtige
Marokkaner gute Nachrichten gibt's von
der Inflation die ist in Deutschland im
Oktober weiter gesunken waren und
Dienstleistungen kosteten im Schnitt
3,8% mehr als ein Jahr zuvor meldet das
Statistische Bundesamt nach ersten
Berechnungen das ist der niedrigste Wert
seit Ausbruch des ukrainekriegs der
Rückgang sei vor allem auf fallende
Energiepreise zurückzu führen
Nahrungsmittel bleiben teuer
Paukenschlag in Bayern kurz vor der
ersten Sitzung des neuen Landtags ist
ein gewählter Politiker der AFD
verhaftet worden Daniel hember gegen den
22-Jährigen Studenten laufen
Ermittlungen wegen des Verdachts der
Volksverhetzung und des Verwendens von
Nazisymbolen aus München Patrizia
Schäffer in uhaft statt im Landtag der
22-Jährige Daniel hallemba hätte heute
als jüngster Abgeordneter an der Seite
des alterspräsidenten sitzen sollen
übers Wochenende war nach ihm gefahndet
worden per Handyortung konnte er heute
aufgespürt und festgenommen werden weit
entfernt von seinem Wohnsitz in Würzburg
bei Stuttgart Daniel hember selbst ließ
über seinen Anwalt ein Video auf dem
twitternchfolger X veröffentlichen indem
er sich als Opfer darstellt man wollte
mich einen gewählten
Landtagsabgeordneten drei Tage vor der
konstituierenden Sitzung mit einem
völlig willkürlichen Haftbefehl
einsperren bei einer ratiia in der als
rechtsextrem geltenden Burschenschaft
Teutonia Prag in Würzburg in der hember
aktiv ist waren Mitte September mehrere
Gegenstände und Datenträger
sichergestellt worden darunter verbotene
Nazisymbole und rassistische Schriften
der dringende Tatverdacht
Volksverhetzung und Verwendung von
Kennzeichen verfassungsfeindlicher
Organisationen weil halemba flüchtig war
bestand außerdem Fluchtgefahr so die
Staatsanwaltschaft gegen die Behauptung
die Festnahme hembas sei politisch
motiviert verwarte sich die
Landtagspräsidentin weder das Parlament
noch sie könnten Einfluss nehmen auf die
Justiz sagte sie an die AFD gewandt ich
Erken Inszenierung in diesen Angriffen
die Täter Opfer Umkehr als Muster mit
völkisem Unterton mit dem Ziel das
Vertrauen in die demokratischen
Institutionen zu zerstören langer
Applaus von allen Parteien außer der
AFD wie alle anderen Abgeordneten genoss
Daniel hembember auch in Abwesenheit
seit Beginn der Sitzung heute Nachmittag
parlamentarische Immunität diese wurde
soeben durch das Parlament
aufgehoben das Bundes Kriminalamt hat
ein Lagebild zum Thema sexuelle Gewalt
gegen Kinder und Jugendliche vorgelegt
danach wurden im vergangenen Jahr
17168 Kinder unter 14 Jahren Opfer von
sexueller Gewalt in fast jedem siebten
Fall war das Opfer jünger als 6 Jahre
die Ermittler gehen davon aus dass die
Dunkelziffer noch deutlich höher
ist bei einem schweren Unfall in der
Hamburger Hafencity sind vier
Bauarbeiter ums Leben gekommen am Morgen
war ein Gerüst in einem Fahrstuhlschacht
im Inneren des Gebäudes
zusammengebrochen mehrere Arbeiter
stürzten bis zu acht Stockwerke in die
Tiefe ein Mann konnte schwer verletzt
geborgen werden wie es zu dem Unglück
kam ist noch offen auf der Großbaustelle
sind bis zu 1500 Menschen
beschäftigt ein weiterwachsendes Problem
für die Sicherheitsbehörden nicht nur in
Deutschland ist die sogenannte
clanriminalität Drogenhandel
Raubüberfälle Schutzgelderpressung das
sind nur einige der Delikte die
Mitgliedern von arabischstämmigen
Großfamilien zur Last gelegt werden eine
internationale Konferenz in Düsseldorf
sucht Strategien gegen die
clankriminalität Markus Aust
berichtet zu Hunderten prügeln sie
aufeinander ein im Juni wird das
Ruhrgebiet zur Kampfarena
rivalisierender Clans 160 Personen
werden von der Polizei festgesetzt wird
niemand aus Mangel an Beweisen erfahrene
Ermittler sind hoch frustriert es gilt
offensichtlich das Gesetz der Omerta auf
der Straße das ist als schweigericht der
Mafia die geschäen sprechen nicht mit
uns obwohl sie herausragend geschäigt
worden sind da sind teilweise
tötungselikte versuchte Tötungsdelikte
zu verfolgen die Bevölkerung spricht
nicht mit uns und das aus Furcht und das
zeigt einfach wo der Rechtsstaat steht
in NRWs Innenministerium diskutieren
heute internationale Experten über
Ansätze gegen
Kriminalität ein Vorschlag strengere
Umsetzung der sogenannten
beweislastpflicht wir brauchen eine
klare und eindeutige
Beweislastumkehr das heißt im konkreten
wenn jemand eine Plastiktüte voller
Bargeld mit sich führt dann muss er oder
sie nachweisen woher das Geld kommt und
nicht umgekehrt dass wir als Staat
nachweisen müssen dass sie illegal das
Geld erworben haben auch Prävention ist
Teil der Strategie in NRW suchen Polizei
und pädag gezielt nach Jugendlichen
kriminellen bieten antigewalttraining an
um die Kurve zu kriegen wir wollen dass
die jungen Leute da nicht dring hängen
bleibenings das mühsamste muss ich sagen
deswegen fand ich so schön dass die
Schweden sagen das Modell übernehmen
wollen gegenseitig von Erfolgsmodellen
lernen zentraler Schlüssel beim Kampf
gegen
clankriminalität die meerwererft hat
damit begonnen ihr neues
Kreuzfahrtschiff zu überführen die
Karneval juubilee reist von Papenburg
über die MEMS Richtung Niederlande der
luxusleiner ist 345 m lang 5000
Passagiere können auf dem Schiff Platz
findinden angetrieben werden soll es mit
Flüssigerdgas am Ziel in emsafen folgen
weitere
Ausbauten und damit sind wir beim Sport
bei den deutschen Fußballfrauen morgen
geht's in der nations League gegen
Island ja das zweite Spiel des neuen
interimstrainers Horst rubesch nach dem
Erfolg gegen Wales ist ein Sieg auch in
reikerwg Pflicht das spel hatte das Team
souverän mit 40
gewonnen die deutschen Fußballfrauen
unter Druck Abschlusstraining vom Spiel
gegen Island der alte neue Trainer aber
bleibt gelassen wir brauchen die Punkte
wir müssen die Spiele gewinnen und so
gehen wir die Geschichte auch an das hat
am Freitag bei der rubesch Rückkehr
schon mal prima funktioniert begeisterte
Zuschauer sahen viele Tore und viel
Dominanz die Isländerinnen aber wissen
dass das deutsche Team ein Sieg und
viele Tore braucht und sie hoffen auf
Lücken vielle jetzt gut für uns Sie
werden hoch anlaufen weil sie einfach so
viele Tore wie möglich schießen wollen
ein Sieg für Deutschland Pflicht denn
sie wollen sich den olympiatraum
bewahren das Spiel morgen Abend bei uns
zu sehen im Livestream ab 19:55 Uhr ja
und dem Hauptprogramm ab 20:15 Uhr DFB
Pokal Kaisers Lautern gegen Köln die
pfelzeer mit starkem saisonst in Liga 2
und auf Rang 6 Köln dagegen in der
Bundesliga schwach und nur Tabellen
Vorletzter
Steffen Baumgart haben seine Kölner in
dieser Saison bisher keine rechte Freude
gemacht negativer Höhepunkt die 0 Z se
Pleite am Samstag in Leipzig damit ist
der Erstligist seine Favoritenrolle beim
Zweitligisten los was uns auf pzenberg
erwartet ich glaube das wissen wir ich
weiß es vielleicht nicht einige Jungs
weil sie das noch nicht erlebt haben im
fritzwalter Stadion dürfen sich die
Kölner auf 50.000 zumeist lautstarke
Zuschauer gefasst machen die ihr Team
wie am letzten Samstag beim 3:3 gegen
den HSV zu offensivem Fußball geradezu
verpflichten mit dem besten Sturm in
Liga 2 könnten die Roten Teufel durchaus
für eine Überraschung gut sein sowie
damals unter Meistertrainer Otto
Rehagel die FIFA hat Spaniens
exfußballverbandschef Luis robiales für
3 Jahre gesperrt der hatte nach dem
WM-Finale Weltmeisterin Jennifer emoso
übergriffig auf den Mund geküsst und
weltweite Empörung ausgelöst Spaniens
Fußballerin waren deshalb in den Streik
getreten obiales will aber Berufung ein
Ding allerdings mit wenig
Erfolgsaussichten danke schön bit
draußen bleibt nass und mild die Details
hat gleich östtin terli um : Uhr begrüß
Sie Christian Sievers im heute journal
hier geht's jetzt gleich weiter mit dem
ZDF spazal alles Gute ihnen und bis
morgen wenn Sie mögen auch wieder
Sinn
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ja der Oktober ist
ja nun fast vorbei und was schon mal
klar ist es ist eines der fünf wärmsten
oktobermonate seit 1881 und der nasseste
seit 2002 und nass und milild geht's ja
weiter wir haben es hier mit diesem Tief
hier zu tun über Deutschland war es im
Laufe der Nacht allmählich nordostwärts
abzieht aber sie sehen auch hier an den
Alpen gibt's ein Tief was die Wolken an
die Alpen herandrückt und hier regnet es
und schneit es teilweise ergiebig und
auch Richtung Balkan das ganze
verabschiedet sich ostwärts in der Nacht
also der Regen der nach
nordostenenziieht und von Südwesten her
lockert's auf dazu Temperaturen 6° an
den Alpen und 12° ganz im Osten ja und
morgen dann teilweise regen die in
Bändern durchziehen aber auch später
Schauer dazwischen auch auf Lockerungen
bei höchsten Temperaturen von 13° z.B im
Osten 14 im Westen und 9° an den Alpen
die kommenden Tage am Mittwoch im
Nordwesten Regen sonst Auflockerung
teils Sonne im Süden und Donnerstag
wird's vor allem im Nordwesten stürmisch
damit einen schönen Abend